[Music]
our talk is run club functions
everywhere my name is Stuart Riesling
I'm the product manager for Google cloud
functions with me I have Justin Greyston
now I'm a customer engineer based out of
London specializing in telco media and
technology companies cool
after that housekeeping please rate the
session in your app afterwards we want
to know whether you liked it whether you
hated it what could be better questions
feel free to shout them out or we'll
have mics at the end you can also find
us outside answer anything that you want
to know cloud functions who here has
heard of cloud functions okay pretty
much everyone nice who's actually used
cloud functions also a lot of people
okay cool so we're gonna talk about
stuff that should be hopefully
interesting to you if you've already
used the product and also some sort of
more fundamental stuff if you don't
really have much experience with it just
to make sure that we have a common sort
of base of understanding about what the
product does so cloud functions what do
I tell customers when they ask me why it
is one server list functions so it's a
managed compute environment it scales
automatically up and back down you don't
get any requests you're not paying for
it you don't manage infrastructure it's
all a very seamless
you know straightforward experience part
of that is the streamlined development
model you just write function code you
issue one command we're gonna walk
through that in a couple of minutes and
then you get it running very simple
also events integration so triggers to
have your function run you can send HTTP
requests you know get post you get a
nice URL we'll show you that too we also
integrate very nicely with different
event sources within Google cloud
platform so for example Google Cloud
Storage you get a file to that you want
to have your function run just a very
simple example of type of events
integration that we offer with this
product I'm going to talk through some
of this
that we announced at next this year
because as the product manager for cloud
functions nothing hurts me more than a
customer who comes up and says I really
like cloud functions but you only
support node we support many different
languages this year at next we announced
Python 3 7g a node 8g a go and 11g a we
also announced a private alpha for Java
8 and go 112 I'm gonna be putting up
links at the end of this session with QR
code so you can snap a picture get you
signed up for those as well
yeah node 10 also in beta the focus of
this talk is actually going to be about
node 10 but the main idea here is we
want to provide a very streamlined
developer model it wouldn't really be
streamlined if we said you know you can
only use node we want to make sure that
your favorite language is very popular
languages are supported because this
whole experience should be very
streamlined simple and familiar to you
as a developer who likes one of these
languages second thing we announced so
when we first launched cloud functions
we only supported one region Iowa u.s.
central one we announced three new
regions at next last year this year we
announced also London and Hong Kong
we're gonna be adding more regions
throughout the year we'd love to hear
from you where else you want functions
this helps us prioritize where we're
going to next we also announced a
feature called max instances and these
are basically scaling controls and the
idea is when you send traffic to a
function we automatically spin up new
instances for you to handle that traffic
sometimes that's great other times you
might want to control the degree to
which your function scales so here is
you have a sequel database that can only
tolerate you know up to 10 connections
at the same time well if you get a
thousand requests to a function and each
of those hits your database you might
break some things so max instances
allows you to say hey only spawn 10
instances and that will allow me to make
sure that my server list stuff works
very well with my non scaling
non-service stuff the last feature that
is important here is server list VPC
access and the idea here is cloud
functions traditionally has not been
able to communicate with stuff inside of
your V PC network
we now support this feature which allows
you to communicate with your Google
compute engine instances cloud memory
store for Redis is a huge one I hear
from customers all the time that they'd
love to be able to support talking to
their Cloud memory store instances you
can now access those from cloud
functions you can also access resources
in peered VPC networks and on-premises
networks that you access through cloud
VPN ok enough recap about the new stuff
we launched cloud functions 101 I'm
going to walk you through the developer
experience so that people can see you
know what is this thing actually about
this is an example of a function written
in node.js you export a function called
hello world this specifically is an HTTP
function which means that we want to
make the experience very seamless and
very familiar so you get HTTP objects
that are familiar to you as a node
developer any node developers in the
audience yeah phew ok cool so this is
based on Express Jas Express is a
popular web application framework so
requests in response are objects that
are there those objects from that
framework so this should all be very
familiar so you write this function it
takes these arguments and then it sends
a message back to the caller hello cloud
next very simple three lines of code the
next thing you do is you want to deploy
that function so we provide a tool
called G cloud G cloud is the tool that
you use to manage all of your Google
cloud platform resources you say G cloud
functions deploy my function name here
is hello world you specify that you want
it to use the runtime node js8 and you
specify a trigger this is the HTTP
trigger it's going to give you a URL
through which you can access your
function that looks something like
region project cloud functions net slash
hello world
you can now visit this in your browser
you can curl it and it will respond back
with that message and so what we showed
you here is it's super simple to get
started you write three lines of code
you issue one command and from that you
get this thing that just kind of
magically works in the cloud scales for
you it does this sort of
resource-based billing model where you
only pay for what you use and all you
had to think about was this tiny little
bit of code that you wrote so these are
really simple building blocks and you
can build really powerful things with
them we see a couple of different
patterns that customers often use I hear
people ask me you know how should I use
this product how should I think about it
so Justin you want to talk about some of
the things you see among customers yeah
absolutely I mean car functions are
really powerful and flexible um but I
think these four three areas are where
you see a lot of customers using them
event based architectures so company
based out of London a media company
called seven digital and use Google
Cloud Storage triggers and then using
that with cloud functions to create a
complete new content supply chain and
you have another pattern that I've seen
quite a lot is where you're decoupling
on-prem legacy systems which have been
tied to like consumer facing apps and
now those those systems you need to keep
them around but they're they're not web
scale right so by using like pub/sub and
cloud functions you can then be couple
those systems okay so the idea here is
you write a function you deploy it you
say hey I want this function to run when
somebody maybe puts a file in Google
Cloud storage or when someone puts a
message on a pub subtopic yes so like
let's say you know somebody buy
something that goes into a legacy
database you then put that transaction
into pub/sub and then you can have a
cloud function that runs and then puts
that in to say firestore which is a web
scale database cool awesome the other
category we see often is data processing
um so I talked to a company out of
Europe in farm they do really cool stuff
in the agriculture space they have farms
distributed throughout Europe and at
each of these farms they have IOT
sensors small devices that transmit
messages back saying what the status is
of those sensors and they use cloud
functions via a pub subtopic that
carries that sensor data to them they
aggregate that data they put it in
different databases they put it you know
in a dashboard so that they can see the
status of
they're farms across different countries
and so what you see here is a very
simple sort of data processing model
where you get messages you're doing
light ETL and then you you put those
somewhere else cloud functions a great
way to glue that stuff together
yeah and cloud automation as well
another thing that we've seen is where
you have multiple cloud products and you
may want to use the cloud functions to
glue those products together so let's
say for example everything's going into
the stack driver logs somebody creates a
VM or a firewall you can create a filter
and create a sink and stack driver which
goes to a pub subtopic and you can tie
your cloud function to that pub subtopic
and that cloud function can then check
with cloud security command center like
whether that there's a policy violation
for example whether a firewall has been
created that is to open and then that
can be then the cloud function can
report a correlation cool yeah so
stackdriver for people who don't know is
the suite of logging and monitoring
tools all pretty much all google cloud
products are very well integrated with
it the the idea again is from a cloud
function or when a VM spins up I can go
you know console.log some message
imagine like console log error I can
then say hey I'm gonna filter messages
that contain error based on those do
something you know send maybe an email
to your security person or to whoever's
in charge of reliability send an SMS
it's a very flexible way for you to kind
of glue together your cloud products and
what you're doing in GCP but it all
starts with one simple command G cloud
deploy my function G cloud functions to
play my function and this command it
looks deceptively simple but it comes
with a whole bunch of cool stuff so for
the price of one g-cloud command what
are you getting clearly when you write
three lines of code and type this one
command that's not really enough for
your function to then be running in our
cloud so what's happening behind the
scenes one is you have a build step
during that build step we take your code
we upload it we then start a cloud build
job cloud build is our tool our product
that allows you to build container
we install dependencies if you're a no
developer it would use npm install which
is super familiar to you if its standard
node.js tooling we add some code that
runs your function we're going to talk
about that more in a second and we build
a container on our infrastructure cloud
functions are really just containers
running on our server list container
infrastructure so the output of this
step is that you have a container image
it contains your code some additional
code and your dependencies what happens
next we deploy your function your
function we we take that container we're
gonna connect a trigger to it so if you
say HTTP we're gonna give you a URL
we're gonna create an instance of your
function that runs in our data center we
then perform a health check we make sure
that what you gave us can actually run
on our infrastructure and then we start
to migrate traffic over gradually and so
now you have this container that is
ready to receive requests on our
infrastructure you read a couple lines
of code we built a container image we
made sure it actually runs and now it's
ready to run so the last thing we do is
we run it when you send traffic to it
we're out those requests to your
function we auto scale instances of your
function so if you're not receiving any
requests you have zero instances you're
not paying for anything it scales down
to zero you get a ton of requests we're
gonna scale up a whole bunch of
instances to meet whatever your QPS
needs are we invoke your function when a
request comes in and we generate some
logs and metrics one of the challenges
that we hear from customers is around
observability and so we want to make
sure that when you're using cloud
functions you have a very easy way to
see you know what's actually going on
what are the errors that are generated
what are the log statements that you're
outputting and so again you went from
three lines of code one g-cloud command
to an auto scaling function that
responds to inbound requests we handle a
lot of the gory details for you so that
this is actually very simple and this is
great for most scenarios when you create
a managed product like cloud functions
you want to try and solve as many use
cases as you possibly can but often when
you're working on a project you might
have you know one specific need
that kind of falls out
of the the realm of what is supported on
cloud functions and you know it doesn't
happen too often but when it does happen
it's really annoying and your resolution
there often is you know I try to talk to
customers all the time the customer will
come to me and say hey could you please
add this custom binary to my container
because I need to have that run inside
of it
well the way cloud functions is built
today what actually would happen if I
put that custom binary in there is that
everyone's function suddenly has that
thing living inside of their container
clearly that's not tenable if it's a
hugely popular binary then yeah we'll
add that to support a lot of use cases
but one single customers really specific
thing is hard to add because I have to
convince everybody else that they
actually want that so what if you
actually need more control what if you
need more control around building your
function the example of a custom binary
is a great one
you want to have something run inside of
it you know what do you do if the
product does not support that what do
you do if you need more control over
deployments so as I mentioned cloud
functions is live in six different
regions what if you need your function
to run in a very specific region for I
don't know regulatory reasons what do
you do if your function needs specific
resources to run so a great example is
today on cloud functions we offer five
different instance types in ranging in
memory from 128 Meg's all the way up to
2048 well what if you need more what if
you need more CPU what if you need GPUs
again you could you know send me an
email and say hey I'd really love to
support GPUs and I'll tell you yes we'd
love to do that too might be six months
or a year from now well you need to
solve that problem today a great way to
kind of explain this is to go back to
the basics what is a function well as I
explained earlier it's really just a
container and that runs on our server
list container infrastructure that
infrastructure is managed by Google
within that container there are a few
different things one of those is an
operating system ubuntu in most cases
this is the value of being on a managed
product is that we patched that
operating system for you we make sure
that the best we can there are no
security vulnerabilities in it all of
that stuff gets handled for you by us
when you're on a managed product inside
of that container is also a run time in
this example it would be the node.js
binary if you're writing a Python
function
you know there's Python inside of there
and again that's managed and patched by
us on top of that there's this bit of
code called the functions framework and
we're gonna talk about this in depth but
the main idea is it manages your
functions life cycle you gave us a
couple lines of code we put in an
operating system a binary clearly that's
still not enough to write to sort of
make your function available and run it
the functions framework is what does
that and then on top of that you've got
your function code your dependencies
this might look like a simple node.js
function like the one we have there you
might have a package JSON file which is
what you use as a node developer to
specify the dependencies of your
function and this is the part that's
managed by you let's talk about this
functions framework a little bit more
and just to be clear this stuff is
available today it's a real thing is now
available open source also I'll talk
about that more in a second
the nodejs 10 runtime on cloud functions
is based on this functions framework if
you deploy a function today to cloud
functions and you say runtime nodejs 10
you're going to get you know the runtime
that is based on this function it's
available as an NPM package NPM is node
package manager you can install it using
standard node.js tooling and it the
source code is all available in github
it's it's an open source project you can
see it we've had people already
contributing issues questions you can
contribute commits we love full requests
and the fact the reason I put this
sticker on top about it now being open
sources the functions framework has
always existed we haven't always called
it the functions framework but there's
clearly always been this code that takes
your function and makes it runnable now
we're making that you know more of an
open sore we're taking that in an open
source direction where you have this
package which you can install if you
want to it's going to give you some nice
benefits
which we'll walk you through and the
code is also fully inspectable so that
you could go up and say hey actually
this is a great idea I want to make some
slight tweaks I want to create my own
thing well here's a great way to kind of
get started with that so let's talk
about exactly what the functions
framework does so that you have a good
sense of if I use this code what's it
actually doing for me
and I should also mention that the stuff
I'm about to talk about if you take away
two things from this talk it's when the
functions framework is awesome the
second one is that it's completely
optional if you're using cloud functions
so you can go on you know deploying
functions the way you always have you
don't have to actually think about this
stuff or know about this stuff but if
you do know about it it can give you
some nice benefits so we've got your
container within that container we're
gonna focus on these top two layers
first one is your function code we've
already seen this a few times now pretty
straightforward it's an HTTP function
nodejs
the functions framework manages your
functions lifecycle and what I mean by
that is okay the first thing it does is
you know spoiler alert it's actually
just an HTTP server under the hood you
don't need to know about that but that
server it exposes your hello world
function on slash hello world so if you
send it a request to slash hello world
it's going to run your function the
second thing that this functions
framework does is if you have a client
that sends a request to your function it
sends an HTTP request well it's gonna
take that HTTP request transform it into
objects that are specific to your
language and it's going to invoke and
run your function by passing it those
arguments again these are expressed jsr
arguments for Python these would be
flask arguments for a different language
there would be something different but
it's very idiomatic it should feel
extremely familiar to a node.js
developer so that function gets invoked
passes those arguments your function
runs and it reaches that rest send block
it's going to send that back to the
functions framework the functions
framework takes that transforms it into
HTTP and sends it back to the client so
all this stuff is pretty straightforward
you
could write this stuff yourself with you
know a couple hundred lines of code
nothing too magical going on but the
really nice thing here is I can just
write this function deploy it not think
about any of this stuff and I'm just
thinking about my function and why
that's important is that you really care
just the the value you can provide as a
developer is in the business logic in
solving the problems that your business
faces you don't really provide too much
value by writing an HTTP server and
making sure it's exposed and handling
marshaling or unmarshal enough arguments
all that stuff is important but it's not
really what you want to focus on and
spend your development resources so that
was a lot of talking let's switch to a
demo just is gonna show you what this
actually looks like in practice yeah
okay so this is the biggest monitor I
think I'm ever gonna have is that all
viewable is that clear enough yeah
that's big enough so simple function
you've seen this time time again in in
the deck nothing fancy going on here
we got package.json no dependencies so
it's as vanilla is it possibly again did
I mention again as a node developer like
none of this stuff should be surprising
to you this is a node.js function it's
an HTTP function exactly what we just
showed you package JSON is the file that
you use to specify some you know it
describes your your module or your
function you can put dependencies in
there all of this stuff as a node
developer should feel completely natural
yeah so first thing we're going to do is
we're gonna just deploy this function
we're not gonna do anything or just put
these three lines of code we're going to
deploy this out and I'm going to specify
the node.js runtime ok talk amongst
yourselves I'm regretting not having a
bash script right now okay runtime and
I'm gonna create an HTTP trigger and
this is using node.js 10 the the slide I
showed earlier with code was using
nodejs 8 and you're probably looking at
this thinking what's the big deal I just
saw this why are you repeating yourself
and that's exactly the point is
no.10 you just change from no js8 to no
js' ten boom you're good to go and we're
good to go
hopefully here we guys I'm gonna deploy
that to you u.s. East one while it does
that I switched to a different Joe yeah
and so like again you're just deploying
the way you normally would you know and
as I mentioned you don't need to know
anything about the functions framework
if you don't want to this is what you
get if you actually do know about the
functions framework yeah so we're gonna
just npm install any node.js developer
this is completely you do this time and
time again functions framework okay
so what's happening here is you're using
the node package manager to install this
package it's going to add it to your
package JSON and see how that just
showed up on line 12 and now you're
saying hey my function depends on this
functions framework okay so that's that
installed we need to do one more thing
okay we need to add a stop script say
that's functions framework I know I'm
belaboring this point as a node
developer adding a script super
idiomatic it totally fits the idioms of
nodejs
you should already know how to do this
you don't need to learn any complicated
stuff and what justin is doing here is
he's saying hey my start command says
run functions framework look for this
specific function and then he's going to
specify the function signature type as
HTTP the reason you do this is because
we also support an events based function
signature type and you tell us which
signature to use so that we know how to
transform incoming HTTP into the right
arguments and invoke your function
properly and because it's completely
idiomatic we can now just do the start
script and what's really cool without
any emulators and I hope my function
running locally on my machine it's just
a local development server the way you
would get if you were using you know
flask on Python or various other web
frameworks you now have this function
that you can send requests to you can
very quickly iterate even if you're not
connected to the Internet you
have this thing running locally you can
send it requests and it will run your
code so that's kind of cool knowing
about the framework gives you this very
simple local development experience that
lets you bootstrap a functional and we
should also have the same function
running on cloud functions yeah so what
you were just seeing on the screen
switch back from this the sec is this is
what the output you get after deploying
a function it sort of describes what
just happened you know some
characteristics and attributes of the
function it also gives you this URL the
HTTP trigger URL and like people who
have worked on provisioning HTTP URLs
know that this stuff is actually kind of
a pain it's not super easy but we
through our tooling make this super easy
for you you now have this thing that you
can click you can send traffic to it you
can send HTTP posts get payloads and it
will just run and you can grab all of
the stuff that comes as headers because
you're getting these idiomatic
you know HTTP objects in nodejs or in
the language that you wrote your
function the function is framework isn't
just about running locally is it right
so let's go back to slide deck thank you
thank you okay so run functions in more
places local development cool that's
great but like if this were all I was
showing you I feel like you'd be
disappointed because the title of the
talk is run cloud functions everywhere
and this is just two places so where
else could we run our functions well if
you know about K native and it's not
that important that you know about K
native I'll explain it briefly you can
also run your functions in K native
environments K native environments are
environments that run containers that
scale automatically and have you know
they're basically serverless
environments from the developer
experience perspective we announced two
products that are K native environments
at cloud next this year one of them is
cloud run the other one is cloud run on
gke if you don't know what these are yet
I'm about to talk about them so your K
native environments basically tell it's
a standard for
how you run containers in a service
manner your functions scale up they
scale down there's a serving API to
which these two products adhere and we
can now take your function with the
functions framework and run it in these
other container based environments let
me recap what cloud run is and what
cloud run on gke is so one is its server
list containers you build a container
using by specifying a docker file you
can now run that on our cloud run our
service container infrastructure so you
wrote some code you wrote a docker file
you did docker build or you built it
using some other product and now you
deploy that to our infrastructure that
will scale automatically for you
there it takes HTTP requests you only
pay for the resources that you use you
can bring your own container as I just
mentioned you're gonna write a docker
file with a docker file like if you're
not familiar with containers it's not
that scary but it gives you a huge
amount of flexibility so you can put in
that whatever binaries that you want you
can specify specific rules and it gives
you way more control than you can get
just by writing some source code you can
say hey apt-get install blah and that
will allow you to put custom stuff in
there and then the last piece is you
know it says cloud run and cloud run on
gke and I'd encourage you to breed up on
cloud run or cloud run on gke after the
talk but you have this common experience
where you can build a container and
deploy it you deploy it to either cloud
run which is a fully managed environment
that runs on our infrastructure it's
actually the same infrastructure that
cloud functions runs on or you can
deploy it to cloud run on gke which runs
inside of your google kubernetes engine
cluster and you know why would you want
to do that well it gives you an even
bigger degree of control and we'll talk
about that in a second so you've got
these two environments that can run
containers how do I run my function in
those environments well remember that
cloud functions when we build your
function it's really just a container at
the end of the day that runs on our
server list container infrastructure
you can take full control over that
container using the functions framework
by specifying a runtime by specifying an
operating system you can build that
container yourself and now you can
deploy that to cloud run and cloud run
on gke so whereas with cloud functions
you just write some source code you type
a command and you deploy it if you want
to go down this path which i think is a
super interesting path because it gives
you way more flexibility you can write
your function code add the functions
framework write a docker file build it
into play and it's actually quite a
seamless experience we'll show you that
in just a second let's demo okay say
same function slightly modified if we're
gonna have a function and we want to
make it portable we don't have a
hard-coded string so I've just used me
an environment variable with a backup
just in case I forget to set the
environment variable that's okay so yeah
pretty much the exact same thing except
line 10 rather than saying hello cloud
next it takes this message which in line
1 says hey check for this environment
variable or no message set we're gonna
set the environment variable okay so I'm
gonna deploy this with the environment
variable because I've already deployed
this function I don't need to specify
the runtime you can do but I'm gonna do
region why don't you add the runtime I
think you'll look better on video later
ok ok so now we just need to set the
environment variable that's all we need
to do you don't do this it's just gonna
say no message set it's not gonna be
very nice down ok nothing that'll be
yeah alright let's go ahead and deploy
that this is the same deployment command
as earlier except we're also specifying
the environment variable ok you should
you shell while that deploys ok let's
deploy cloud run it's very first thing
we need is a docker file
super simple docker file is hardly
there's more comments in here than
actual
actually there's like five or six lines
that you actually write and act this is
a totally standard nodejs docker file
yeah
and the and so we're taking note is ten
now you zoom in from the top yeah
no best no J's ten base image creating a
location to run your operating system
yep the operating system and the runtime
binary node and then we copy the package
Jason we do that in a separate step
because if you don't actually update
your dependencies we don't want to
rebuild that layer in the docker
container we copied a function across
and then we have our NPM start like we
had running it locally okay so you
specify the operating system you copy
stuff into there you do NPM install to
make sure the dependencies are installed
inside of that container and then on
line 20 this is just the command that
will be run when your container starts
up and now justin is using docker which
in the machine yeah on the local machine
you could also build this in the cloud
docker is the standard sort of container
building and management tool chain and
he's saying build my container and he
gives it a name that container gets
built you could see that was super fast
because a lot of stuff is already cached
because we've done this before maybe and
then he's gonna take that container
which he built locally and he's gonna
put that on Google container registry
Google container registry is just a
place that stores containers for you so
right now he's uploading that container
it's gonna be on Google container
registry it has a name so you went from
function source code added a docker file
built the container pushed it and now
it's ready to be deployed so Clare run
betta so we need to add the betta ok
this should be looking very familiar
very if your functions if you use DG
cloud with functions this is very
familiar right run to our functions now
it says run yeah that's it and instead
of the function we want to invoke would
just need to give a service name it will
if I can type it will remind you if you
forget I've done that lots um
and I'm going to deploy this to a
different region
this case your central we need the image
yeah so rather than specifying a runtime
here he's saying hey just take my image
from Google container registry with this
name and then again very very familiar
in fact absolutely identical to what we
just did in cloud functions we set the
environment variables and this time we
want to say hello okay so what's gonna
happen here is once he enters this
command cloud run is going to go and
fetch that image and deploy it to the
cloud run infrastructure we do many of
the sim of the same things that we
showed earlier where we take that image
we start it we make sure it's healthy we
start to spin it up for you and there's
one difference here is by default
services and cloud run are private but
for the sake of this demo we're gonna
say let's allow an authenticated yeah if
you didn't do that it would just give us
an error which okay so we got another
environment week and apply to you know
I'm gonna deploy that same function into
kubernetes okay so let's sharpen the
gamal tools no we don't need to yeah if
you've used kubernetes before you know
you have to write a lot of gamal to
deploy something one of the really nice
things about having cloud run and cloud
run on gke is cloud run and gke is
kubernetes under the hood but you don't
have to actually write any gamal you get
a very seamless developer experience
using g-cloud the command-line tool and
by the way you can do all this stuff in
the UI - in the user interface we're
just using G cloud because it lends
itself well to a demo and we see that
pattern a lot among developers and so to
do this Justin before this talk set up a
google kubernetes engine cluster you can
do that via the UI that thing is now
sitting there he installed into that
cloud run on gke and it's sitting there
waiting for him to deploy a container to
it okay so you can see this is identical
ready so far there is no difference okay
we're gonna say hello
you'll see why we're setting the
environment variables when we show you
these things running it's gonna show you
this message to see okay sure that we're
not faking it
yeah and the last thing we need to do is
we need to actually say which cluster do
we want to deploy into okay so rather
than saying hey region which region
would be a region one of the ones
supported in cloud run in Google's data
centers he's gonna say hey this cluster
which he's called cloud - run - gke
is where I want to deploy this function
- and we need to tell it where the
master node lives which is a US West one
okay let's just double check I think
we're good so that's gonna deploy that
out into my Cuban Nettie's cluster
exactly the same if I'm a developer and
I have an ops team looking after my gku
cluster it's I don't need to worry about
all of that it's it's a service
experience yeah that's a good point is
cloud run and gke well you have to have
a gke cluster it's not you know as
managed as the cloud run experience is
if you already have a cluster it's a
great way to actually get started and
get as much as you can out of your
functions if you don't have a cluster
yet say the easiest way to try this
stuff out is to just go for cloud run
because that's fully managed yeah okay
so let's just recap we deployed to three
different environments with exactly the
same function the only different was the
environment variables yeah and we've
gone to cloud functions cloud run well
you wrote a little docker file - yeah I
did but yeah it's the same function code
that doesn't we didn't have to change
the actual code exactly okay so
hopefully if the demigods are playing
nicely we should say hello from GTF and
us worst oh you got a nice HTTP URL that
you can invoke there and then we go to
club run and we had across the u.s. - US
Central and we should have another URL
serving traffic at yep it gives you
another URL yeah there we go
hello cloud run in US central and then
finally we had the same going into my
Cuban eTI's cluster which is a set up
free County yeah I didn't know Nisan
Caroline NGK in us West okay cool so you
just took the same code
you added a framework and you added a
docker file and you deployed it to three
different environments so we've
established that you have portability
among these environments when you're
using the functions framework and you
just want to write functions can we go
back to the slides please so your
functions are portable you can run them
on cloud functions you can run them
locally you can run them on these
different environments but like what's
the big deal
right like portability so what who cares
well for one these environments are all
server lists which means you have a very
simple developer experience you have
auto-scaling to meet traffic up and down
you have HTTP triggers where you have a
URL that you can hit to make your
function run then you also don't have to
manage infrastructure and I'd be kind of
lying if I put a little green check in
the bottom right box you do have to
manage a gke cluster it's still
significantly easier than if you try to
do this yourself but you know just be
aware that if you want to do cloud run
on GK you have to have a GK cluster but
there's a good reason for using like we
haven't really touched on for using like
GK it was like if you wanted to
particularly use like GPUs like say oh
okay oh okay so why how do you think
about these three different environments
first one cloud functions go from source
code to a running function within
minutes I mean what we just showed you
is pretty simple you write a couple
lines you issue a command boom you're
good to go
cloud run why would you want to do it on
cloud run well when you write that
docker file you can put arbitrary stuff
in there gives you fine grain control
over what actually goes inside of the
container maybe you need a very specific
binary maybe you need to have stuff
built in a certain way well if you write
a docker file build it deploy cloud run
you have an auto scaling function that
includes whatever custom stuff you need
to put in there so it gives you more
flexibility more power a little bit more
responsibility in terms of what you put
into that darker file but also more
power
cloud run and gke very similar sort of
story you can run it now in a
self-managed cluster within that cluster
your function will scale up and scale
down according to the size of your
cluster and that cluster can obviously
grow to as your your needs kind of
change but you can run it in that
cluster with even more control for
example you need specialized instance
types like GPUs now you can have this
function code that you wrote deployed it
to cloud run on gke where you have an
instance pool that includes GPUs or more
CPUs specialized instance types and your
function can use those resources and so
this is a pretty cool way of thinking
about the portability aspect is I can
write my function code once and I
realize hey I actually need this
specialized thing okay well I can move
it to cloud run and I can do that maybe
I need something even more specialized I
can move it to cloud run on gke and I
can do that too without needing to
change my function code as we start to
wrap up I just want to highlight that
this is just a first step you know what
we showed you here is just node 10 I'm
sure a lot of people in the audience
also want Python Go Java all of the
runtimes that we support on cloud
functions the new ones that we're gonna
be releasing are based on this functions
framework model that's going to give you
that nice local developer experience
it's going to give you that portability
to different cloud environments hey one
thing I should call out too is I showed
cloud run on gke and I mentioned earlier
that these are K native environments
there are other K native environments
provided by you know companies that are
not Google IBM for example has a K
native environment the the container
that you build can run on that
environment too so this isn't just
portability within Google Cloud it's
also portability a monk a native
environments provided by other providers
or even on-premise yes you can run K
native in your cluster on-premises and
you could run your function there so
back to the runtimes all new runtimes
that we're going to be releasing are
going to follow this model it will give
you that local developer experience
it'll give you that portability you know
Python we're planning to when Python 3:8
comes out that's going to be a functions
framework
based model we also see this functions
framework as a great way that we can
start to integrate additional
functionality into your functions so one
example here is I want to be able to see
my trace data imagine I have three or
four functions calling each other I want
to see the life cycle of a request as it
passes through those different functions
so that I can see you know which one
takes the longest where does this thing
get caught up we can add those things to
the module that is the functions
framework so that in each language you
suddenly get this functionality for free
built-in and when I say free like these
services do sometimes have a cost but I
mean that you you don't have to actually
add this boilerplate code to every one
of your functions it just comes nicely
integrated and then also you know a lot
of the talk today was based on HTTP we
also support events so an event style
signature and we do have more work to do
on bringing these events to other
platforms but we're working with the CNC
F which is the cloud native computing
foundations cloud event spec so we
support that today if you send cloud
events to the function the functions
framework will automatically convert
those into objects relevant to your
language and these are the pieces that
we think are really key to providing a
good functions experience it should be
easy it should be well integrated so
that you don't have to write a bunch
boilerplate it should support events
obviously and we think we can do all of
this through the functions framework so
with that as we wrap up there are a
couple of sessions that I'd point you to
if you want to learn more about what you
saw today most of these have already
happened but they're gonna be up on
YouTube as well if they're not up
already so what's new and serverless
compute goes much more into app engine
cloud functions cloud run what's all the
new stuff some really cool demos in
there too that show us scaling up you
know from 0 to almost 10,000 instances
to handle a request load within like 5
seconds which is pretty mind-blowing we
also have a cloud run session which will
go much deeper on how you actually use
this product what are the features and a
cloud run on gke session similar but
about cloud run on gke so with that I
want to say thanks some links here this
is all going to be up on YouTube
if you need to capture those later cloud
functions Doc's also the functions
framework repository which is live today
on github and the cloud run Doc's great
ways to kind of get familiar with the
products your feedback greatly
appreciate it as I said at the beginning
please add it to the app tell me what
you liked tell me what we can do better
next time this this is super helpful to
me and I will leave these private Alfa's
these are QR codes for the go 112
runtime in the Java 8 runtime these will
lead you to forms if you fill those out
we're adding people on a weekly basis we
can add more people you know if we can
get you added to those as well and if
you miss these
come get me later they'll also be on the
video that's hosted on YouTube
[Music]